لذلك لعقود من الزمان ، طفل واحد
ثم تذهب إلى طفلين ، أنا مهتم
بأنهم وضعوا بالفعل رقمًا
عليه ويقولون في الواقع ثلاثة ولا
يقولون فقط لديهم ما تريد ،
نعم ، إنهم يضعون سقفًا لهذا ريتشارد
ولكنهم أيضًا  نتوقع أن
يؤدي هذا إلى طفرة المواليد كما اعتقدوا عندما
قاموا بتغييرها من طفل
إلى طفلين مرة أخرى في عام 2016. ومع ذلك ، لم
ينتج عن ذلك في الواقع استمر في
التدهور ، والآن
نحن هنا في وضع تكون فيه
الصين  حقًا في وضع صعب بالنسبة
لسكانها المسنين
لأن ما لديك هو هذا الانخفاض في
معدل المواليد أضف إلى هذه الزيادة
في متوسط العمر المتوقع ولديك هن
قوة عاملة شا
ة وشابة ولكنها أيضًا تتقدم في ال
ن وبالتالي فهي  لست متأكدًا من
كيفية استدامتها على المدى الطويل ،
أعتقد أن الشيء الآخر الذي يجب عليك
فصله عن كل هذا هو أن هذا لا
يتعلق فقط
بالاقتصاد والازدهار وهما شيئان
مهمان للغاية
هنا في الصين لأن
كلاهما متجذر في الاستقرار الاجتماعي  هنا حتى
إذا كنت  ليس لديك عامل الرخاء هذا ،
فقد يتعثر الاستقرار الاجتماعي
والحكومة المركزية الحكومية
التي ترى بالتأكيد أن الشيء الآخر
المثير للاهتمام للغاية أن نلاحظه
هو توقيت هذا الثراء ، فقد جاء هذا
بعد أسابيع من أظهر تعداد 2020
أبطأ نمو في  عقود هنا في
الصين ،
لكنه يأتي أيضًا كإعلان
من
القيادة العليا للحزب خارج
التجمع الوطني ، المؤتمر الشعبي الوطني على
وجه الخصوص ، وهذا بشكل عام
عندما
يتم طرح بعض هذه الإعلانات الرئيسية
بدلاً من ذلك ، يأتي هذا
بعد أسابيع من التعداد السكاني.  يوضح
أنه أمر
مطلوب على الفور التعامل معه وأنه كان
عاجلاً ولهذا السبب يأتي من الأعلى
هنا السؤال
هو هل سيكون له تأثير جوهري حقًا هل
سيشجع الناس على إنجاب أطفال
لا يزالون  نرى أن هناك
حقائق على الأرض هنا ريتشارد
هذا مجتمع متقدم
أصبح
مكلفًا بشكل متزايد
ينظر كل فرد في العائلات إلى أن الأمهات
والآباء بدأوا في رؤية تكاليف السكن
وتكاليف التعليم العامة
في ارتفاع
، ومن ثم لتحقيق التوازن بين هذه المطالب
وفكرة إنجاب المزيد من الأطفال
بشكل جيد بالنسبة لهم ، فإن الأمر يتعلق بالحفاظ على
نمط حياة معين أيضًا
و  لذلك فهي مقايضة صعبة
وليس
من المحتمل حلها بسهولة هنا
ريتشارد